all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here Darius everyone has been saying
that the world is going to end that
we're headed to a recession and then the
GDP number just dropped and it
absolutely blew away expectations what
the hell is going on
yeah man it kind of reminds me of like
the old school Mortal Kombat you know
you remember we had like the Finish him
move the the GDP data and also the PC
report that we got on Friday was kind of
like the Finish him for like the the
ultra bearish narrative and so I think a
lot of folks who have been you know
fighting this this Equitable Market the
bull market we've seen in credit year to
date I think a lot of folks are going to
throw into town capitulated in the
second half of the year so let's start
with this first chart here uh we'll be
talking we show a real GDP accelerating
and beating consensus expectations in
the second quarter uh real GDP came in
at 2.4 percent on a quarter for quarter
annualized basis that's the highest
print we've seen since the fourth
quarter of last year um if you go down
to the third panel in this chart where
we show uh the I components so gross
private domestic investment that number
accelerated to 4.8 percent on a
quote-over quarter annualized basis and
contributed 100 basis points to that
headline GDP figure of 2.4 percent
that's the highest number we've seen
since the first quarter of last year so
economy's doing doing quite fun
now when we go and we look at June
number specifically there's uh some
nuanced data here that's kind of telling
a story that I think reinforces the
macro GDP number what are you seeing in
the June data yeah absolutely so if you
look at this chart here where we show um
industrial production capacitization
manufacturing and trade inventory but
specifically want to focus drives to the
the bottom two panels where we show
durable goods new orders as well as core
capital goods new orders and just by for
by way of reference uh when you see
these charts from us the blue bars
indicate the court over quarter or three
month annualized rate of change and then
the red line just shows the year of year
rate of change but we're primarily
focused on uh the sequential the
three-month annualized rates of change
here 42 macro because we believe that's
where more Market information lies but
again if you go back and you look at
these um the June durable goods uh print
came in at 32.4 through month annualized
that's the highest number we've seen
since September of 2020 and then core
capital goods new orders came in at 5.7
percent on a three-month annualized
basis so that's the highest number we've
seen since August of 2022 so uh you know
wherever you slice and dice it would be
GDP whether it be durable goods capital
goods new orders you know the U.S
economy very much looked like it's um
it's growing quite as robust and quite
robustly now you can look at all of the
actual Goods themselves but if you just
go look at what consumers are doing with
their pocketbooks they're spending yeah
what are we seeing here yeah that's what
we've been saying man and look the US
economy is exemption-oriented economy
right we know that 68 of GDP uh is
consumer spending and on Friday we got
the June pce report which I happen to
find is this outside of the jobs report
arguably the most important uh economic
statistic that comes out on a monthly
basis uh and when you look at the top
panel there where we show a headline PC
so real personal consumption
expenditures they accelerated to 2.9
percent in June that's a three-month
High uh and it was driven primarily by a
rebounding Goods consumption uh where we
saw a good sub uh real Goods PC
accelerate to 5.4 percent on a
three-month annualized basis that is
also a three-month high now when we look
at income growth I think this is one of
these metrics where like real wages have
been down for like two years because of
inflation being so high and obviously
people start to politicize those numbers
but when we look at income growth that
seems to be telling a pretty positive
story as well
yeah 100 man so uh real wages let me
just take a quick set a second to take a
step back there real wages have been
negative in terms of just specifically
wages or at least they had been prior to
2023 for a while but the reality is
consumer income has not been negative
because again we're seeing total growth
in employment it's not just wages you
also have employment as well you have
government transfers and other avenues
in terms of supporting income growth and
so if you uh look at income growth
specifically in the PC report so again
we get two respending in that report we
get consumer income in that report and
we also get inflation as it relates to
the consumer economy in that report so
let's start with the income here uh so
personal income this is nominal employee
compensation so it's the broadest most
nominal measure of income that we
receive from the labor market on a
monthly basis that number accelerated to
6.2 percent uh through month annualized
in June um that you know that's that's
the highest number we've seen since
September of last year and that really
matters because you know in nominal
employee accommodation or employee
compensation is right around 60 or a
little bit over 60 percent of total
income growth another interesting
statistic I derived from this particular
chart here now if you go down to the
fourth panel there where we show
personal interest income uh that number
accelerated to 8.8 through month
annualized in in June uh that's the
highest number we've seen since January
of this year so when you put those two
factors together nominal employee
compensation interest income you're
talking about 70 of consumer income is
growing somewhere between six and nine
percent on a three-month annualized
basis that just does not sound like an
economy that's anywhere near a recession
now when we start thinking about the US
economy more broadly this idea of it
being resilient keeps coming up or like
a resilient economy theme describe a
little bit what some of the factors that
feed into that are yeah absolutely man
so you and I've been talking about this
for almost a year now it's you know we
created the theme in August of 2022 it's
August of 2023. uh We've added some
things to the list but primarily most of
the stuff was uh readily available
um if you were doing the research back
last summer to understand that the US
economy is likely to remain resilient
for longer than the average you know
investor understood and the reality is
um you know so there's eight factors
that we see as independent factors but
all being very relevant uh there's
number one is near record cash
on household balance sheets number two
you have near record cash on corporate
balance sheets number three you have
private sector income and wealth have
outpaced inflation on a structural basis
so clearly you know the big issue is
okay inflation is very high you know
it's you know we had the negative wage
growth that you cited earlier but the
reality is since the inflation episode
started you know going back a couple
years ago we're still seeing income and
measures of wealth like you know
household Network for instance of those
numbers have actually grown faster than
inflation has on a cumulative basis uh
number four we've limited credit cycle
vulnerabilities I mean I'm sure you've
heard this a thousand times how credit
card debt blink you know credit card
that blank but I'll throw a couple
statistics at you just specifically as
well as to um consumer um consumer
leverage so if you look at household
debt uh relative to the Domino
disposable personal income so that's the
broadest measure of income you have as
consumers here in the US economy that
number is 85.5 percent uh in June that's
exactly the same as the trailing 10-year
mean so there's been no sort of
degradation in terms of um you know
consumers getting over covered in any
stretch and even when you look at it
specifically as it relates to credit
card debt that number is right around
4.9 percent as the percent of that
nominal disposable personal income
that's below the trailing 10-year mean
so you could take all those tweets about
credit card debt and stuff which is what
I said a year ago and put it in and put
it in light it in a dumpster fire with
all the other bad economic statistics
that people keep trying to cite uh with
this uh with this faulty bearish
narrative um the reality is that we got
a few more here to get through so we
have limited exposure to the volatile
manufacturing sector manufacturing
sector is way more volatile relative to
the services sector it accounts for
about 98 of net job loss in a recession
on a median basis going all the way back
to the post-war U.S economy we have a
longer long and variable lags at least
according to our estimates based on you
know how much what the percent of debt
that's been sort of um termed out uh
both within the household sector and
also in the corporate sector as well
um you know you also have this you know
these record spreads between or not
record but near record spreads between
you know let's say a marginal mortgage
relative to the effective mortgage rate
that everyone's pay saying or relative
to the yield on on corporate credit
instruments relative to the coupon that
the corporates are actually paying so
what's happening is folks aren't going
to the market to buy a new house they're
not going to the market to issue new
debt and so ultimately what it means is
that monetary policy is just going to
take longer to really hit the economy
because we're seeing that stasis develop
and lastly we've got biodynamics this is
something we saw on last Thursday's GDP
report but if you look at um government
investment is growing plus 11 on a
three-month annualized basis it's also
growing plus 11 on a year of year basis
as well so it's been pretty persistent
that trend of of government investment
and then lastly you have Labor hoarding
which is something we've talked about on
the program as well um labor Hoarding in
the sense that it's been very difficult
because we've seen this structural
decline in the total labor force
relative to uh prior to the pandemic
it's been very difficult for U.S firms
to attack attract and retain talent and
so as a function of that they've
probably just been more unwilling to
fire people in this particular business
cycle than they otherwise would have
given how much you know kind of tithing
we've seen thus far bidenomics is still
the uh most hilarious title of all time
because it feels like it's used both for
positive and negative descriptions but
regardless of what uh what what people
have from a perspective it's just the
policies have led to the results and you
can judge them for yourself when we
think about transitory Goldilocks uh I
know that's something that you've been
thinking a lot about what are we seeing
here
yeah absolutely so uh you go back to you
know January this year when we I
identified the transitory Goldilocks
team it was it was based on our
realization that hey look this
Immaculate disinflation is real right we
have the resilient U.S economy theme
since going back to last summer but we
became pretty clear to us and you know
in January and I think you know we were
you know we were among um you know other
investors who kind of came up with that
at the same time I shouted my man Bob
Elliott over and limited you know it's
hey we actually are experiencing this
Immaculate disinflation because what
tends not to happen in the U.S business
cycle is inflation breaking down before
a recession but we've that's exactly
what we've seen so on Friday we've
gotten pce uh the PC report within that
we get the PC deflator so this is uh the
broadest measure of inflation
specifically for the the household
sector and the US economy or for the
consumers in terms of consumer spending
and so there's four statistics that are
really important in that particular
report I'll start with the uh one two
three four the fifth panel which is core
PC inflation so that's the fed's
preferred measure of inflation this is
the one that the FED cares about the
most that number decelerated 3.3 percent
on a three-month annualized basis that's
the lowest print we've seen since
February of 2021 so that's pretty that's
pretty robust and what's likely to
happen in the coming months is that the
year of year numbers are going to
continue to chase the three-month
annualized rates of change lower that
should certainly happen as well for
super core uh PC inflation which is the
bottom panel there so super core PC
inflation is core Services PC inflation
X housing this is the one that pal keeps
setting at all these fomc press
conferences and that number uh
decelerated to 3.2 percent on a
three-month annualized basis that's the
blue bars in these charts that's the
lowest print we've seen since July of
last year uh we're also seeing it on a
broad base measure as well so if you
kind of go back up a couple of panels
where we show median pce and trim Bean
PC those numbers came in at 3.8 and 3.4
respectively both of those were the
lowest numbers we've seen since August
of 2021 so we're making significant
progress as it relates to you know
getting inflation under control and it's
coming from you know some pretty
important Avenues as well if you go to
the next line now when we look at things
in the private sector uh you've got a
couple of panels here what's going on
yeah so so this uh this chart here just
following up on this um Immaculate
disinflation discussion here so again
obviously the Brazilian economy that's
the first collection of charts second
collection of charts here is this kind
of updating investors on where we are in
the somatically disinflation process and
I'll draw your eye specifically to the
bottom panel in this chart where we show
the private sector employment cost index
and so that's the broadest measures
wages and salaries that are at least on
a quarterly basis and that's the one the
FED kind of really cares about to kind
of anchor monetary policy on and so you
know historically we were kind of
trending around two two and a half
percent that's that's pretty much you
know anything right around two and a
half percent is pretty much consistent
with two percent inflation so we're
clearly very north of that but we are
making um decent progress
um if you look at it on a quarter over
quarter uh annualized basis uh the
private sector employment cost index
decelerated to 4.1 percent in the second
quarter that's the lowest print we've
seen since the second quarter of 2021 so
if we continue to make this kind of
progress you know it's definitely going
to call into question whether or not the
FED is going to be able to continue to
make interest rates uh in September
don't forget we got two more CBI reports
uh between now and in the September
meeting I think we have one more PC
report and then we have two more job
supports so uh you know they're going to
be busy in terms of interpreting this
data now when you start looking out uh
kind of at what the FED is seeing here
we obviously got the interest rate hike
is this something where they can just
keep hiking forever or are they pretty
much uh saying to themselves look we get
the green light because the economy's
strong and we can go higher is it uh
wait we're going to over rotate how are
you thinking about this yo it's a great
question man so it I think they're done
for now you know they may go on what it
feels what may ultimately feel like
elongated pause because I don't think
between now and the September meeting
fomc meeting that they're going to get
you know any data that has a material
change in terms of its flavor you know
we have this Immaculate disinflation
it's probably going to slow down the
pace of the Immaculate disinflation But
ultimately as we show on chart 8 I'm
actually quite concerned that you know
by the time we get roll the clock three
to six months from now you know you know
beyond the FED meeting I think that the
air of inflation can very much shift
from Immaculate disinflation to Sticky
uh inflation and that might ultimate
ultimately you know kind of cause the
FED to to um you know to get off this
high horse and Implement another rate
hike or so so we'll see I don't know
that the really I don't really have a
strong opinion on that but what I do
have a strong opinion on is that as we
show here in chart eight if we continue
to see this rally in energy and food and
energy prices um we have WTI on the left
chart there it just recently broke out
to bullish from the perspective of
volatility just a momentum signal by we
have agriculture which has been bullish
for maybe a little bit over a month now
relative to our relative decimal minimum
signal if those bullish Vans you know
kind of conditions persist for the next
few months we will see another surge in
inflation just similar to kind of what
we saw in the first half of 2022 so
that's something that's concerning me
but another thing that's concerning me I
think we might have talked about this on
the program as well which is
the immaculate his inflation was
probably going to run out at some point
anyway in the second half of the year
just based on where we are in the U.S
business cycle and the likelihood that
it's very unlikely that we see inflation
return back to two percent prior to a
recession we do believe inflation is
heading back to two percent but we also
we also ultimately think that we got to
go through recession to get to that so
if you play the clock forward in terms
of how the market narrative might change
between now and let's call at the end of
the year right now it's saying economy
is resilient we've got a medical
disinflation you put those two things
together we got transitory Goldilocks I
think between the in now and the end of
the year some point in Q4 maybe even it
spills over to q1 but I think the
narrative around the resilient economy
will dissipate and sort of you know kind
of and part of the reason the narrative
around the really the driving force
behind why the narrative on the economy
being resilient will dissipate is
because the narrative surrounding
Immaculate this inflation will change
and if we shift back to something that
looks like sticky inflation and
ultimately a Fed that has to do more
tightening it gets pushed the economy
into a recession that's going to cause
the resilient economy narrative to to
unwind so you you know I think six
months from now is probably going to be
a very different feel in asset markets
it could be sooner you know I don't have
a crystal ball and like when that
actually is going to come up but I do
believe you know when we get into the
fourth quarter some of the data is
probably going to look a little bit
different than what it does today
when you look at asset prices you see
the fed's actions we go into the end of
the year there's this whole thought
process of like you know may hit and go
away
is that true or do you think asset
prices got a shot through the rest of
the year oh I think they do I think
we're going to make all-time highs in
the Spy we said this uh last week a
couple times and you know based on the
the reality based on the you know the in
our analysis of this data it's very
unlikely we see a significant change in
the conditions of you know these kind of
themes Immaculate disinflation you know
resilient U.S economy equals transitory
Goldilocks I think if we have another
three months of that we are going to
make all-time highs in the Spy I mean
you just see what happened over the last
three months you know it could very
easily add another 200 s p points in a
matter of a couple of months so I do
believe all-time highs and the s p are
very likely but that doesn't necessarily
mean it's the start of a new Raging Bull
Market because again I still think the
market is going to have to price in at
some point between now and you know the
first half of next year into the first
half of next year something we call a
phase two credit cycle downturn which is
the process of the market you know
trying to find a Lowe's trying to find a
low in earnings and corporate
profitability in a recession and the you
know the correction and valuations that
we typically see you know that allows
different businesses different investors
to capitalize you know businesses and
take over new businesses that process is
months if you didn't argue it's probably
months away at the early it's probably
four or five months away hit the latest
probably seven eight months away and so
if you you think about you know how long
how much time that is in Risk Management
terms you think about just think about
where we were four to five months ago in
pricing terms seven eight months ago in
pricing terms and you can kind of roll
the clock forward on that
when we had to look out over 2024
obviously the economy is uh some people
think it's going to go into a recession
at the end of this year beginning next
year there's this positive kind of
undertone to it uh housing prices is the
last thing I want to talk about real
quick what we've seen is they were
pretty resilient and now there starts to
be some softening in it how much of uh
economic pain could potentially just be
lagging a lot of the interest rate
decisions versus some of the data points
we talked about today you think can
overpower that stuff and actually we're
on our way back kind of up as an economy
and and the FED uh we'll give it quits
and walk away
no that's a great phenomenal question
man so um we've been doing this for how
long of course I asked phenomenal
questions that's true yeah I think
you're one of the world's best man and I
appreciate uh being on with your
community so um in terms of answering
the question I I think so we we are we
believe a recession is still the most
likely probability uh our model since
November of last year has been centered
on uh the six-month interval between Q4
of 2023 and q1 of 2024 as many recession
is most likely to start so that's still
our Baseline scenario you know we'd have
to go through q1 of 2024 for us to Now
cast our way out of that um and so in
terms of like the resiliency that we've
seen since then this wasn't an Impulse
there was not like a new thing that
created the resiliency it said that
there was the economy was always
resilient it was just being
underreported and the market the price
change and the market price here today
has really forced the mainstream media
to you know to stop doing whatever the
hell it is that they're doing all day
and actually acknowledge the fact that
the economy has been resilient you know
this is the stuff we do every single day
it's seems boring you know trying to
figure out what the three month
annualized rate of change of durable
goods is is boring as hell but you got
to do it in order to get these themes
right
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about 42
macro yeah I appreciate it man so uh
definitely come check us out 42macro.com
uh 42 macro weather is my Twitter handle
pretty active on there as well so uh
definitely give us a drop I appreciate
you I learned something every time we'll
do it again
appreciate you man thank you so much